Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwoods Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with a warning about Muslim
immigration into the United States that
comes believe it or not from none other
than Hillary Clinton the Washington
examiner reported recently that at 42.4
million there are now more immigrants
legal and illegal in America than ever
before fueled by a massive flood from
Muslim nations and while the doors
remain open on the US Mexico border the
biggest percentage increases in
Immigration are all from largely Muslim
nations what could possibly go wrong
with this scenario Hillary Clinton knows
the answer to that question as she
herself revealed in a 2013 email that
makes her Current public position on
immigration absolutely
inexplicable The Examiner added that
according to Steven A camarota and Karen
Ziggler of the Care Center for
immigration studies the sending
countries with the largest percentage
increases in immigrants living in the
United States from 2010 to 2014 were
Saudi Arabia up 93% Bangladesh up 37%
Iraq up 36% Egypt up 25% and Pakistan
India and Ethiopia each up
24% now Hillary despite her
determination to increase the number of
Syrian refugees entering the United
States by
550% knows very well the risk involved
in this massive influx of Muslim
immigrants and in her scheme to increase
their number even more The Daily Caller
recently reported that in a private 2013
speech Hillary Clinton worried about the
risk of jihadists entering Jordan with
legitimate refugees because she said
they can't possibly vet all those
refugees yes Hillary Clinton said that
Clinton said this in a speech before the
Jewish United Fund of Metropolitan
Chicago she said so I think you're right
to have gone to the places that you
visited because there's a discussion
going on now across the region to try to
see where there might be common ground
to deal with the threat posed by
extremism and particularly with Syria
which has everyone quite worried Jordan
because it's on their border and they
have hundreds of thousands of refugees
and they can't possibly vet all those
refugees so they don't know if you know
jihadists are coming in along with
legitimate refugees turkey for the same
reason yes Hillary Clinton said that
Clinton made this vow during her second
presidential debate with Donald Trump
she said I will not let anyone into our
country that I think poses a risk to us
so she apparently believes that while
Jordan and turkey cannot vet the
refugees and winnow out the jihadis from
among peaceful Muslims the United States
government under a Hillary Clinton
administration will be able to do so
this is an extraordinary claim two
Muslim nations are unable to distinguish
jihadis from peaceful Muslims but a
non-muslim nation will be able to do so
Hillary Clinton could only Advance such
an absurd proposition in a world in
which non-muslim spokesmen such as John
KY David Cameron and Pope Francis
pronounce confidently and
authoritatively on the nature of Islam
blly contradicting Islamic law and
Theological consensus as well as the
closely argued konic exegeses of
numerous Jihadi leaders in telling us
that Islam is a religion of peace that
rejects every form of violence Clinton
herself has declared Islam is not our
adversary Muslims are peaceful and
tolerant people and have nothing
whatsoever to do with terrorism yes
Hillary Clinton said that also since she
is so sure that she knows all about
Islam and Muslims Clinton is doubtless
sure that she will able be able to
ensure that US immigration and Refugee
authorities will not let anyone into our
country that I think poses a risk to us
yet when she makes statements so
divorced from reality as her claim that
Muslims have nothing whatsoever to do
with terrorism she doesn't exactly
Inspire confidence that Those whom she
thinks pose a risk to us will be those
who actually do pose a risk to us even
worse when as far back as 3 years ago
she indicated that she had some idea of
the difficulty even for Muslim countries
to vet the refugees properly her
advocacy of a steep increase in Muslim
immigration is at very least
astonishingly irresponsible her position
appears to be based on a toxic
combination of willful ignorance and
hubris toxic not for her presidential
chances but for the possibility that a
Hillary Clinton presidency would be
anything other than an unmitigated
disaster for the United States I'm
Robert Spencer